[Music]
okay so what just happened here what you
just watched is me unlocking a phone
with my fingerprint through the glass in
the display
which is pretty dope that's like a
glimpse into the future of smartphones
so for unlocking our phones lately for
the last couple years we've gotten used
to fingerprint readers touch id became
that standard and now pretty much every
phone that comes out has somewhere on it
this fingerprint reader for unlocking it
but lately they've gotten shoved to like
the back of the phone or the sides or
just off of the front entirely to
accommodate these full screen phones the
bezel-less revolution the infinity
display now i personally love the idea
of shrinking bezels and i can see that
future smartphone being completely
bezel-less all screen but that does of
course come with a couple sacrifices one
of which being
where do we move the fingerprint reader
you can put it on the back like we've
seen a lot you could put it in the power
button on the sides there's a couple
possibilities you can even go the apple
route and totally remove it iphone 10 of
course has no fingerprint reader and
they've moved over to facial recognition
or face id but synaptics has been hard
at work on their own solution and that's
what you just saw working it's called
clear id but whatever the name doesn't
really matter what matters is it's a
fingerprint reader underneath the
display glass so the sensor itself is
called the fs9500 it's made by synaptics
and it's being shown in this vivo phone
called the x20 plus ud it's a pretty
weird name but it's on sale and
everything it's the first phone that has
this fingerprint sensor in it so does it
work in the exact same way that all
these previous fingerprint readers have
in the past almost sort of so you enroll
your fingerprint in the software just
like any other fingerprint reader you
can do more than one finger if you want
and then you'll notice i didn't scan my
finger until a little indicator light
turns on this is kind of how you know
it's ready to scan and where to put your
finger and then this is literally an
optical sensor so it's a cmos sensor the
same type you'd find in a camera or in
the smartphone camera itself actually so
in order for it to work number one it
has to be an oled display it'll only be
found in phones with oleds and number
two it has to be shining a light on your
fingerprint for it to reflect back under
the glass and read it so when i put my
finger on that indicator which is
basically a helper for guiding my finger
to the right place you see a light shine
for a second a sort of a pulse that's
long enough for it to read the
reflection of my fingerprint on that
optical sensor it's literally lighting
up my finger for the sensor to see so
you go from the screen off to raising
the phone which lights up the indicator
touching your finger to it pulsing the
light and reading the fingerprint reader
plus this pretty slick animation
all in under a second and a half which
is not bad so all that's pretty
impressive and it usually brings a
couple of main questions to mine number
one being does it affect the performance
of the screen in any way no and number
two
can you see it like in the display at
all if you tilt it to the right angle
can you see the sensor and that answer
is yes if you look hard enough and while
the screen is off at the right angle
with just the right amount of light you
can see the little rectangular sensor
under the display but it's definitely so
subtle that you wouldn't notice it if
you weren't looking for it and of course
once you turn the display on or light up
any pixels around it even at the lowest
brightness it's completely invisible so
this is definitely really promising i
was personally impressed trying it
myself and i think the biggest thing
obviously for it to improve is that
speed like i mentioned it's all about a
second to a second and a half to do
everything it's faster than face id but
it's slower than touch id it's think of
it as like a first gen of a new touch id
in the future though consider this
because this is just the first
generation of what we're looking at it
doesn't just have to be in that exact
area it's not limited to just the little
rectangle in the middle that's just
where we're expecting it so that's where
they put it but it's unlimited in size
it could be the bottom third of the
phone it could be the bottom half of the
phone
it could even be the entire display all
of the glass could have a huge cmos
sensor underneath it that reads your
fingerprint so i could see a phone in
the future where you just take it out of
your pocket and just touch it anywhere
and you're in you're unlocked because
you touched the screen but anyone else
trying it wouldn't get in that's kind of
like the ideal biometric authentication
it's what face id wanted to be so with
that in mind this first generation being
this good already is pretty promising
and it means we're closer to our goal of
course of a fully bezel-less phone as
far as phones we could see this in in
the future we're not going to see this
in the galaxy s9 probably not going to
see it for the next lg flagship or the
note but maybe a little after that i
mean the sensor's out there now it's in
this vivo phone but like i said it's a
bit slow so you know the big
manufacturers the lg's and apples and
samsung's of the world aren't going to
put this first gen product in their
phone but i could see even as early as
next year us having a much better much
more refined version of this start to
show up in phones a lot more often so
i'm looking forward to that let me know
what you think is this what you're
expecting in the future of the iphone
and the galaxies let me know until the
next one thanks for watching talk to you
later
peace